this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist use the link in the
description and you'll receive one free
week and 25 off a premium membership
you're in a classroom your professor
walks in and goes to his desk at the
right hand side of the front of the room
he places his messenger bag on the desk
and takes out a handful of papers he
says something but you're not really
paying attention
then it suddenly hits you you realize
you have a test today not only a test
but a final an exam that could make or
break you you begin to panic you didn't
prepare at all and you barely remember
any of the information in fact you're
not even really sure what will be on it
you look down a test paper has been slid
in front of you it appears to be
completely blank though you're confused
and overcome with anxiety your heartbeat
begins to reverberate through your whole
body your professor notices you and
quickly comes over your panic
intensifies
are you okay you don't look too good he
says to you
you try to pull it all together but when
you go to say that you're okay you can't
you can't seem to get the words out and
you suddenly can't seem to really move
at all
then in an instant you black out
the next thing you know you're waking up
in your bed
this visceral seemingly real experience
suddenly becomes a vague memory of a
dream
the trope of waking up from something
that suddenly reveals to be a dream is
arguably so cliched in story film and tv
that it's almost unusable at this point
but there is arguably good reason for
why this is the case why it has and
continues to be such a common
storytelling device
it points to something so profoundly
strange and yet so ordinarily common
that each and every single one of us
experiences each and every single night
something that if we think about it long
enough can both unsettle and astound us
about the mysteries of consciousness and
reality of sleeping and dreaming
in the words of fernando pessoa whenever
someone tells me he dreamed i wonder if
he realizes that he has never done
anything but dream
the average modern american adult gets
around 7 hours of sleep per night over
the course of an average lifespan of
about 80 years that means the average
person spends around 23 years asleep or
about one-third of their lifetime
there are five stages of sleep across
two main categories non-rem and rem
sleep
starting in non-rem we move through the
first four stages where the body and
brain increasingly relax and slow down
the breath and heart rate reduce the
body's temperature decreases and brain
waves slow becoming what are known as
delta waves
this period of non-rem sleep makes up
around five hours of sleep per night or
around 75 percent of sleep in general
there are essentially no dreams during
these stages and so as far as we can
tell there is no thought or conscious
experience at all
our subjective experience of self
appears to disappear a strange almost
mystical loss of self into nothingness
and so at around 75 percent of sleep
this means that across your lifetime you
will spend around 17 years in this state
essentially equivalent to death
at stage 5 however you return and you
enter into the second category of sleep
rem sleep during this stage the brain
paralyzes the body the eyes dart back
and forth like a glitching animatronic
the heart rate and breath spike back up
and the brain returns to a near awake
state
and here is where most streams occur
throughout an average night we cycle
through the five stages about four to
six times and we spend about two hours
per night in the stream stage or around
25 percent of sleep in general
and so across your lifetime you will
live about six years
in a dream
in this other strange state of sleep
where the lines between reality and
non-reality blur and an entire seemingly
self-created realm is experienced
but what exactly is this realm what are
the implications of experiencing it
something that seems so real but isn't
why do we experience it how do we why do
we even sleep and dream at all
despite all modern science and
technology and despite how prevalent and
how much of our lives are surrendered to
these years of sleeping and dreaming
these questions remain largely
unanswered
the reasons for why we need to sleep
each night are obvious a lack of sleep
weakens our memory and ability to think
clearly it can cause mood swings and
hallucinations nerve cells may not
function well the immune system can
weaken and much worse
but the reason for why sleep is needed
for these reasons is still unclear
there are of course many theories
related to why we sleep as well as
pertaining to the functions of rem sleep
and dreaming
revolutionary psychologists sigmund
freud and carl jung directed much of
their psychoanalytic efforts toward
dreams both believing that dreams serve
to provide a relevant conscious window
into the unconscious mind freud
specifically believing that dreams were
symbolic representations of repressed
fears and desires jung believing that
they were more often symbolic
manifestations of the collective
unconscious of humanity as a whole
following the 20th century increased
understandings of the mind have also
allowed for neurobiological theories to
form like activation synthesis theory
which argues that dreams are merely a
product of random neural activity taking
place in the brain stem and in the
cerebral cortex attempting to make sense
of the meaningless activity by forming
thoughts and stories out of it
other theories suggest that dreaming
helps memory learning or forgetting
unnecessary or harmful information
dreaming either being a primary or
secondary phenomenon to these
neurobiological processes
and theories like threat simulation
theory and social simulation theory
argue that dreams serve as a sort of
practice rehearsal to improve one's
abilities and likelihood of success in
threatening events or important social
situations
these are just a few of the many
theories focused just on dreams and rem
sleep however since the mind is still
largely not understood and since
consciousness is such an unbreachable
subjective realm all theories are
essentially both unfalsifiable and
unprovable
and so there is still no real consensus
on why we dream or how dreams are
created
perhaps most confounding and unsettling
is this last part how the mind creates
dreams
how does it create a reality so real
insider sleeping unmoving head without
ever moving the body or experiencing
anything outside of it in a dream you
experience the physical sensations and
visuals of a world that feels completely
real
to your dream self it is real
and here that classic cliche trope of
not knowing if you are in a dream
becomes eerily uncertain and ripe with
reasons for literary and philosophical
exploration
typically the strange things that happen
in dreams don't seem strange when we are
in them it is only after we awake and
recollect them through what we believe
to be our normal state do we sift them
through a filter of normality and derive
their strangeness
but if things and dreams don't seem
strange when we are in them how do we
ever know that any filter through which
we determine what is normal when we seem
to be awake is not in fact also part of
a dream
when i consider this carefully 17th
century philosopher rene descartes wrote
i find not a single property which with
certainty separates the waking state
from the dream how can you be certain
that your whole life is not a dream
how do we know that we will not reawaken
into another state that will turn
everything that feels normal right now
into a memory of a strange dreamt
reality
of course this is very unlikely to be
true but for the same reasons we cannot
prove or disprove any theories of why
and how we dream because we can't
sufficiently enter the minds of others
nor escape our own we cannot truly prove
or disprove that we are not in one right
now
there are certainly things that seem to
be obvious indications of reality
perhaps things like the level of
perceptual detail the experience of pain
the pace of time and events the
consistency of memories a memory of
having woken up in the morning and so on
but many people have dreams where they
awake at the beginning of it in what is
known as a false awakening in which the
dreamer experiences waking up normally
in their bed often followed by intensely
vivid details of ordinary life but yet
they are still asleep in a dream
and moreover how do you know that your
assessment or beliefs about what is
sufficiently detailed or painful is not
a dreamt conclusion how do you know that
your memories are not dreamt how do you
know that your experience of having
awoken this morning with a memory of
having dreamt the night before although
it felt like you were remembering a
dream you are not actually remembering
reality
in truth it seems that any test or claim
of knowing you are awake could
theoretically take place in a dream
of course again this is extremely
unlikely and is perhaps more to serve as
an interesting philosophical
contemplation as opposed to a
practically useful takeaway but
nonetheless the contemplation shows us
when our reasoning for believing
something is true or real is because
it's obvious that does not necessarily
mean it is
without any concrete knowledge evidence
or way of proving it we find ourselves
on a shaky ground of knowledge and
uncertainty at the beginning and end of
each day
the good news though is that whether you
are in a dream right now or not likely
doesn't matter if you can't know the
difference then what's the difference if
love and fear and meaning is felt in
your dreams apparent truths discovered
and wonders found if experiences are
experienced in anything anywhere does it
matter if it is objectively real in the
way you think
the fact that you exist anywhere in any
way able to experience anything is all
you can and all you truly need to know
and perhaps if we wish to wake up from
our dream if we are in one we simply
need to close our eyes and find the real
world
whether this reality is a dream or not
there is endless information to learn
about it while you are still here
whether you want to learn more about the
nature of reality the science of
dreaming and sleeping the importance of
sleeping for health or anything else
this video sponsor blinkist is an
incredible tool that can help you learn
about all sorts of subjects from all
sorts of books no matter how much waking
time you have blinkist works by taking
over 5 000 of the best nonfiction books
in 27 different categories pulls out the
key takeaways and forms them into 15
minute text and audio summaries that can
be read or listened to even while
offline in doing so blinkist can help
you turn personal or otherwise unused
moments of time like your commute
errands breaks in your schedule and so
on into meaningful and enriching
opportunities to learn more about the
world and yourself enter the strange
world and concept of lucid dreaming on
blankest with the title exploring the
world of lucid dreaming by stephen
labarge and howard reingold in which the
two provide interesting insights about
lucid dreaming a state in which people
claim awareness of dreaming while in
their dreams as well as a guide to
potentially enhance the lucidity of your
own dreams and how this can potentially
contribute to your waking life
use the link in the description and
you'll receive one free week of
unlimited access as well as 25 off a
premium membership the free seven day
trial can be canceled anytime within the
trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general if you
enjoy exploring your curiosity through
content like this then be sure to check
out everywhere else pursuit of wonder
create's content through the links in
the description on the pow instagram you
can find regular posts that challenge
the mind and hopefully help it become
its most dynamic and interested version
of itself